Speaker 1: Donald Trump is preparing to be
criminally indicted, according to Maggie Haberman
of The New York Times, during and after Joe
Biden's summit with Russian President Vladimir
Putin last week, the Republican right did
exactly what we predicted that they were going
to do. They said Joe Biden is going to fail
and he was failing and he did fail without
ever actually explaining how or why Biden
failed. They said Joe Biden has obviously
mentioned we're going to get back to that
a little bit later. They said Biden's not
going to be able to even speak coherently
when he meets with Putin. They said Trump
would have done better, an obviously laughable
claim. But what appears to be going on behind
the scenes, according to a new report from
The New York Times, Maggie Haberman says the
true realization that Trump had as a result
of that Putin Biden summit was that Joe Biden
is really the president right now, period.
There's no reinstatement coming. There's no
nothing. Trump is now reportedly preparing
with lawyers and aides for a legal for a criminal
indictment that they believe may well be coming.
Check out this appearance by Maggie Haberman
from The New York Times on CNN.
Speaker 2: But also, I think that it is he
is missing a level of protection that he.
Felt like he had when he was in the White
House, some kind of, if not actual full immunity,
some level of a belief that people were not
going to charge a sitting president. I think
that he is talking about keeping his political
options alive because he sees it in part as
a shield against what could be coming.
Speaker 1: That's interesting. Do you have.
Speaker 3: Have you heard or what have you
heard about how he is specifically preparing
for this? Because that presents it in a new
light to me at least, that what he's doing
now is all in or at least partially in run
up to things that he fears may happen.
Speaker 2: Look what he's doing in terms of
preparing for a possible indictment is he
is holding a lot of meetings at Trump Tower.
There was a picture the other day of him emerging
from Trump Tower, which I was surprised it
took that long for somebody to see. He was
there. He's been there for many weeks going
back and forth between his club at Bedminster,
New Jersey, and Trump Tower. He is preparing
to describe this as a, quote unquote, political
witch hunt. I think you've heard that before.
And I think he will hear a lot of that if
the prosecution moves forward, as the prosecutors
have given every signal that they're going
to. It is going to be a very familiar playbook.
But again, I just don't think that you can
disentangle these two things.
Speaker 3: He's taking meetings in Trump Tower
on the possible indictment. He's meeting with
lawyers, political infighting.
Speaker 2: He's meeting with advisers. He's
meeting with his sons who were running the
company while he was the president. He is
meeting with his own attorney and say he is
this is a a not the only focus of attention,
but it is a focus of attention.
Speaker 1: Now, as Maggie Haberman points
out, if the indictment comes down, the reaction
will be predictable. It will be this is another
witch hunt. They failed on Russia, Russia,
Russia, and they failed on my perfect Ukraine
phone call. And now they're coming at me again.
The reality is that these are totally unrelated
causes. They are disparate investigations.
They're being carried out in siloed ways by
completely different investigative entities.
And the reality is Trump just did a lot of
stuff that is potentially criminal. Trump
and Republicans want to frame this as there
are so many investigations against Trump because
of the political witch hunt and the biased
nature of everything that's been taking place.
That's wrong. The reality is that there are
so many investigations against Trump because
in so many areas of his life, personal campaign,
business, presidential, administration, there
are so many areas of his life that are just
riddled with potential wrongdoing and criminality.
And it's going to take years to unwind at
all. Also, remember, some of this is taking
longer because Trump successfully obstructed
it while he was president, preventing the
tax records from being provided to the Manhattan
district attorney, preventing on the Rudy
Giuliani side, Trump loyalists at the Justice
Department prevented the raid on Rudy Giuliani's
house and office from being carried out before.
So a lot of this stuff is delayed and it's
going to take a while because Trump successfully
delayed it. Now, as I've said before, if this
indictment comes down, the stakes in my mind
are not does Trump go to prison? I just see
no chance of that. People get mad when I say
it. If I'm wrong and Trump does prison time,
I will eat my microphone. For me. The stakes
or whether the indictments torpedo Trump's
shot at being kingmaker in twenty twenty two
and possibly at running again in twenty twenty
four. I think those are really the stakes
here in a Republican Party that's still mostly
likes Trump mostly supports Trump publicly.
Could the indictments get so in the way that
it leads to Trump being unable to run in twenty
twenty four because he has to beat off all
of these legal cases? Now, hilariously, we
talk about, you know, under Trump, the US
looked a lot like other countries. There are
places like, for example, my birth country
of Argentina where you can be under investigation
and indictment and successfully run for high
level public office. Former President Cristina
Kirchner was charged in twenty eighteen with
bribery and still ran and was voted vice president
in twenty nineteen. This is classic Latin
American politics. While under indictment,
you run and you win. Could it happen in the
U.S.? Sure. You know, after Trump, it would
be silly to say X could never happen because
we had a lot of X could never happen moments
and we were wrong in the United States. But
we will take it step by step in, day by day.
And the latest news, according to The New
York Times, Maggie Haberman, is Donald Trump
is huddled up with his legal team and preparing
for what they expect to be a criminal indictment
coming down against the former president of
the United States. If you think things have
been nuts the last week or two, just wait
until you see what happens if and when Donald
Trump is criminally indicted. Follow me on
Twitter at David Pakman. Let me know what
you expect from Trump, if indeed that that
day comes